tell us about unleashed may i ask like
how that came into your life oh man so
uh you know i got a phone call from
nickelodeon
and it's crazy because i was on a
nickelodeon show
20 years ago and i thought my
relationship was pretty much over
because you know
i'm over 40 now and i'm not really in
you know i can't really do kid rolls
so uh to get a phone call from them it
was like okay what do you guys want to
talk about and they said well
we have a new show that we are coming
out with and we wanted to see if there
was an interest in hosting
and i'm like well you know that i have
some time right now what kind of a show
is it
and as soon as they said animals i i
couldn't say yes fast enough
did you ever like david letterman's like
stupid
pet tricks growing up oh wow
yeah way way back in the day
people love animals and then you
this show has like an american gladiator
spin
on animals it's like two things that
have come together
that have never been together before and
yet
how did we live without this no i'm
telling you it is such
a fun show i had no idea animals could
be so talented and just
do so many random things i think the
highlight for me was watching a squirrel
water ski um which yeah
i can't do that that is in like a sizzle
reel i was watching also
i just totally loved the guy knocks on
the
you know dressing room door and now it
just comes like a horse running out
and as someone who's been in a lot of
dressing rooms like that
kind of humor to me really did it for me
i think you animals nickelodeon it's
just
it's just joy it's fun and everybody can
enjoy the show
and um you actually brought one of the
acts um
to our show and we get to take a sneak
peek into
tonight's show which i'm really excited
about
um i'll introduce them if that's okay
let's meet lauren
and her chicken koa hi
i just want you to know that i have
chickens i have six chickens
so i'm very excited to see what you do
um she performs some tricks she knows
over 100 different commands um
can you show us some yes
i'm very excited
good girl
good job
[Music]
yes
oh lauren and koa you guys are
amazing well thank you so much for
showing us that
it's really impressive um we have a
surprise for you we brought in
our own little animal a talented animal
to show off and see if we can impress
you
please welcome johnny and his adorable
bulldog
cartman
yeah go cartman
wow good puppy
ready to go back ready to go back look
at him
oh my gosh
[Applause]
how's it going hi johnny how are you
good excited to be here so excited that
you came
may i ask when cartman learned to
skateboard
he found a skateboard when he was about
two years old at central park
and he kind of just started kicking and
pushing all by himself all i really did
was just motivated and encouraged him
within a month he was skateboarding on
his own johnny tell everyone
uh the new unique way that cartman gets
ready to perform
oh so he um he has to hump the board
um he kind of like shows like who's boss
and then once he's finished with
whatever he needs to do then he'll he'll
go
but that's kind of his uh his ritual his
uh process
gabriel what are your thoughts on that
preparation
[Applause]
i love that cartman can get away with
that um
well thank you johnny and cartman thank
you thank you very much
thank you gabriel it is such a privilege
and a pleasure to talk to you because
you are a human all ages party and
i'm so glad um that you are in the world
doing what you do
thank you gabriel iglesias don't forget
to catch unleashed on
nickelodeon and all of gabriel's amazing
netflix specials
you